ce procès et à lui seul le procès
d'enfant et le procès de forme
bature au fil des témoignages l'empathie
suscitée par Valérie Bacco ne cesse de
grandir son calvaire paraît surréaliste
les violences endurées
inimaginables manifestement très vite on
sent qu'il y a chez elle une peur une
terreur qui est toujours là la peur de
son mari alors qu'il est décédé il y a
eu une relation de couple pathologique
qui s'est mise en place avec une emprise
terrible de cet homme qui peu à peu
s'est avéré être dominateur violent
méprisant et qui a laminé toutes les
facultés d'adaptation toutes les
facultés de réflexion de logique de
cette femme qui peu à peu s'est enfermée
dans une espèce de bulle mentale où seul
la parole de son mari faisait office de
loi et dictait son comportement au
quotidien Valérie était une femme dont
on a révélé la notion de syndrome de
femme batue et lorsqu'on est battu
pendant des années durant depuis l'âge
de 12 ans on peut pas raisonner comme
vous et moi on est obligé à un certain
moment de faire un geste qui ne
ressemble pas qui ne lui ressemble pas
pour se sauver c'est un geste de survie
enfin entre les les humiliations les
violences verbales les coups la
prostitution elle était dans un climat
je pense qu'on qu'on peut même pas
imaginer en fait ces actes de
prostitution qui ont duré plusieurs
années qu' le manageit lui-même qu'il
dont il était témoin puisqu'il avait
organisé tout un système de de de trous
dans la le véhicule dans lequel ça se
passait pour pouvoir observer ce qui se
passait durant la passe que que qu'
l'avait organisé pour sa compagne tant
le psychiatre que la psychologue on dit
une chose
importante elle a un syndrome de femme
batue c'est une femme qui est en stress
post-traumatique c'est dit noir sur
blanc par un psychiatre par conséquent
elle a toutes les excluses c'est
impossible que la Cour d'Assise la
condamne sévèrement
impossible elles sont toutes pareil
pourquoi elles portent pas plainte
pourquoi elles ne partent pas mais parce
qu'elles ont la trouille parce qu'elles
sont sous crise psychologique importante
qu'elles ont la peur au ventre tout le
temps mais qu'elles ont des enfants
n'importe quel parent peut comprendre ça
[Musique]
elle qui n'avait jamais l'amis à
retrouver une famille elle sent que
finalement aujourd'hui on s'intéresse à
elle qu'elle est quelqu'un elle l'a dit
alors qu'avant elle pensait qu'elle
n'était rien mais elle ne sait pas
encore qu'elle est devenue un symbole
elle a envie de parler pour les femmes
c'est une évidence elle a dit d'ailleurs
qu'elle allait plus tard quand elle
sortirait elle disait qu'elle allait
s'occuper de de toutes ces femmes et
elle était là pour les accompagner les
écouter elle a envie de faire quelque
chose pour que son parcours de vie dans
son horreur puisse avoir un sens et que
ce parcours serve à quelque chose
il y a eu un noralement médiatique dès
le lendemain deand des saisissement ça
m'a un peu interpellé mais effectivement
finalement Valérie Bacco a d'ors et déjà
gagné la victoire de l'opinion
c'està-dire que cet emballement
médiatique cet emballement de
communication a servi la cause de
Valérie Bacco le procès dès le départ il
n'existe pas c'est le procès de Daniel
poulette c'est le procès de la mère de
Valérie Bacco mais ce n'est absolument
pas le procès de Valérie tout le monde
moi y compris est unanime pour dire que
Valérie a tellement souffert
qu'effectivement tout le reste n'a plus
aucune importance c'est important que le
combat des violences faites aux femmes
soi médiatisé puisque c'est laborieux on
savait qu'il allait avoir une
médiatisation au fur à mesure où le
temps allait avancer donc on s'est
organisé pour nous avec les avocates
prendre la parole dans la presse relayer
la parole de Valérie de façon la plus
neutre et la plus représentative
toujours avec l'accord de Valérie quand
il y avait des décisions importantes
entre-temps elle a reçu plus de 650000
signatures de pétitions pour demander sa
sa
[Musique]
libertééminicies
les magistrats n'apprécient pas
vraiment qu'on leur dicte ce qu'ils
doivent faire il n'apprécie pas ce qu'on
appelle le tribunal
médiatique je pense que pour un symbole
des violences faites aux femmes il ne
faut pas prendre quelqu'un qui a quelque
part un peu planifié un assassinat la
médiatisation ateur d'une attente
sociale forte décuplé par rapport à la
situation des victimes de violence
conjugale ce qui est intéressant pour
faire bouger les lignes maintenant ce
dossier est très particulier et c'est ce
que j'ai j'ai vraiment voulu dire tout
de suite c'est que en réalité la
situation de Valérie Bacco à mon sens
dépasse toutes les situations de
violence conjugale que l'on vit tous les
jours en réalité dans les tribunaux où
l'on poursuit des des violents conjugaux
où l'on protège des femmes femmes où on
attribue des des des téléphones graves
danger ou des bracelets antiapprochement
pourquoi y croit et comment on peut y
croire ben parce que déjà il y a 10 ans
il y avait rien rien on n'en parlait
même pas et aujourd'hui on en parle
c'est déjà un progrès
immense de pouvoir alerter tout un
chacun de d'être vigilant sur des
situations de de famille de voisinage
peut-être qui semble compliqué et
peut-être de de faire un peu attention
de mettre des des des signaux d'alerte
et puis il faut pas se décourager he je
veux dire on a tous en
mémoire les combats de confrères comme
Giselle Alimi comme Robert baninter et
s'ils avait baissé les bras on naurait
pas avancé comme ils ont pu faire
avancer les choses que ça soit les
problèmes d'avortement de peine de mort
donc je dis que il faut il faut beaucoup
de courage il faut beaucoup
d'investissement il y a des déction
il y a des
découragements mais on peut pas arrêter
maintenant c'est impossible il faut
continuer deant que la société civile
est avec nous donc c'est
encourageant ont
compris